The Joe Rogan experience, this and that.
Like keep you the best years of my life.
Oh, that's my favorite. I did. I did to
grow once more. We broke up. She said,
I wasted all this time with you said,
oh, I go, I thought we were dating.
Yeah. I didn't know you were
investing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Wasted it.
Oh, you wasted it. Well,
I guess every relationship when
it's over as a waste, like what?
That's so bizarre. Yeah. Bizarre way of
looking at it. Yeah. Enjoy the present.
Enjoy the time you had together.
Yeah.
But if you thinking about in terms of like
hitching around on a successful train.
Yeah.
If your goal is to get married and you're
with someone for five years and then
you break up like, oh, you know,
I should be with someone
else who would have married,
now I've got to find someone else.
Yeah.
The jealousy thing about the, the
breakup is so, it's so normal.
It's so hard for people to
not be jealous. Like, no.
Very few people ever break up and go, hey
man, she's cool. Just didn't work out.
I was Dick. She was, she
needed some growing. We needed,
we both needed time away.
Hey, I wish her well. I've
never really gotten jealous.
Like I always like when they move on,
you know what I mean?
When like when they get a new boyfriend,
you're just like, oh thank God.
Oh that's cause you're a comic.
You have opportunities. Yeah.
But it's like if it's like you're
not their responsibility anymore,
you know what I mean? They can
still like, if they're single,
they can still call you up, you know,
in the middle of the night. Yeah.
I still get mad about things like still
want, let's talk about this again.
Once dating someone else,
you're like, all right.
You said you're someone else's problem.
Now the best is when they have a kid
with someone else. You're like, yes,
that solver baby. Yeah. It never
talked to you again. I'm free. Yeah.
It's interesting. Then it's, it's a,
it's an interesting thing when you decide
to touch naked bodies with the person,
right?
You like create this bond by doing
things with your bodies and spending time
together and then you separate.
But you're always gonna have this yet.
But I used to touch naked bodies with her.
Yeah.
We used to get together and
we used to do things together.
We don't do it anymore, but I
did it. I did it back in the day.
I got her naked and we got naked together.
Yeah. History. Yeah, it's history.
It's weird. You know, she'll
never forget. I won't either.
We touched each other. Yeah. I like
the idea of like relationships.
Looking back fondly on relationships.
I never felt like I wasted my time.
There are people that I've dated that I'm
like probably shouldn't have done that.
But uh, but for the most part I try
to, uh, have good feelings about it.
You don't want to,
you want to hate like a period
of your life now it's pointless.
But there's lessons learned. Those
ones that I've had that were like, Ugh,
that's how, you know what, when you
date someone and it's cool when they're,
they're good. You get it.
Like I dated this girl long,
long time ago who's super negative,
just super negative all the time.
And then I dated this other girl right
afterwards who was non negative at all.
She was always laughing about stuff
and joking around. No matter what.
Like even if like a car getting an accent,
she'd take a deep breath and go,
well that car's fucked up. And she
would start laughing and I was like,
oh this,
there's different ways to handle things.
Like if you get stuck with your
high school sweetheart and and,
and she's a pain in the ass forever.
Like you never understand like there
are the exact same circumstances.
One person's going to handle it completely
differently and if you're with that
person, it's going to be a
totally different experience
where it'll be a bonding
experience versus dem woe is me being
for the next six months and bringing it
back to,
I can't even look at a tourist because
it reminds me of when I got in that
accident,
touristic parts
woo
like fuck, that was a year ago. I like
when people are together for a long time.
They break up and then the guy gets
married to the next woman he runs into
instantly,
instantly.
It's like he just like found the opposite
of what he'd been dealing with and was
just like so over the moon about it.
They had to marry her right away.
That happened to a buddy of mine.
He did an actress and then it was just,
you know, it was just brutal.
Everything was career.
This career that was about her career
was trying to help her career and then
they broke up and he's like,
I'm never getting married again.
A month later he's with this new check
and he's living with her two months later
and then he's married six months later.
I'm like, what happened? He goes,
I realized it wasn't that I didn't
want to be married. He goes,
I just didn't want to be married to her.
Is I realized like there's some people
out there that I get along great with.
Yeah, and if you don't, if you
don't bail on a bad relationship,
you don't know that there's you can
be and you are going to be different.
That's the other thing. Like your d
I'm different with different people.
You're different with something like
you react better to certain people and
certain people's personalities,
you jive better with them,
you have more fun with them.
It's more entertaining. It's,
and you get to like reintroduce yourself.
You know the other person knows you for
this like five year period of time when
you maybe you weren't at
your best. Yeah. You know,
and like when you've already used all
your tricks. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like if you give a girl diamond earrings,
you can never give her diamond earrings
again for as long as you lived.
You know what I mean? It's like that
the president is over right for now.
And then when you get to spend
with someone new, you can,
you know it's a clean slate, right?
You can impress them. Yeah. They, yeah.
They haven't heard you're fucking dumb
stories already that you can like you can
like,
I'll listen to this.
Why I always tell guys strive to be the
person you pretend to be when you're
trying to get laid. If you can be that
person, that real person all the time,
but this is very difficult to do, but if
you can be that person most of the time,
if not all the time, you'll have a better
life. Yes, I would agree with that. Yeah.
But it's fun to try to impress people.
It's fun when you meet someone like, boy,
wait til they see how witty I am.
Yeah. Yeah. It's weird. Like with me,
I'm like,
I don't like when someone just ended me
just because they know who I am at the
like you're a famous comedian.
I'm like a little annoyed,
but if they have no idea who I am,
I'm also a little annoyed like this.
There should be perks to this. Yeah.
That I'm missing out on him. Yeah.
Did you not Google me?
Yeah. Yeah. He's not a fan.
What are you from another country?
What's going on?
Could you imagine dating someone who
didn't like comedy? Anthony, I love you.
You're amazing. But I don't
like stand up. I mean,
if it was someone who just like didn't
like stand up and thought I was great,
I could handle it.
They didn't like stand up in general,
but they like your material in particular.